Dave Rubin host the Rubin report on
YouTube and this is very wise man and
joins us so it's a date as I'm watching
that also they had this kind of panic
feeling and thinking maybe I fell for an
elaborate ironic prank from HuffPo and
then I realize no because they don't
have a sense of humor but reassure me
this is real right Tucker very quickly
on the last segment I swear to you I
thought you were the highest-paid man in
television I am shocked and I'm gonna
you know I don't get I don't get paid
for these appearances but I'm going to
mail you a check for somewhere between
15 and 20 dollars okay that aside this
is yeah you got it my friend listen
these these puff piece of Huffington
poem een these pieces that these that
these authors whatever they are
journalists that they write these are
not pieces of journalism it's so much
easier to destroy and then to create if
you're watching Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer and think it's about racism and
misogyny and the patriarchy and the rest
of it well you can find that stuff
everywhere if you look back at anything
and that's that's what people really
need to understand when these pieces
come out and then you start looking at
something that you used to love or that
used to have a wonderful message about
the holiday and giving and being
accepted and all of those things that
they're trying to take that away from
you and it's not like they stopped with
one thing right they find something they
kind of destroy that and they'll move on
to everything else that we love so you
know eventually they'll move on to
sitcoms that we love whether it's
Seinfeld for you know Zach doing
something they've done or or friends or
whatever else it is they'll go for
cartoons they've gone for Bugs Bunny I
mean they will literally go for a sunset
think of whoever is watching this right
now think of something you love that
brings you a sense of peace and decency
and they will somehow link it to the
patriarchy and the rest of their
politically correct nonsense and we just
need to we need to realize that as I
said earlier it's easier to destroy than
create that's doing and I think you have
to do is create that's such a smart
point what are we creating what is being
created in this moment of destruction
right now do you make me feel that's
what I'm worried about
yeah yeah well that's what I'm worried
about because there is some legitimacy
that some of the thing
is happening in the country and in the
world should be destroyed at some look
we've got major problems in academia
we've got no cherry absolutely so we
want some change but but anyone can burn
anything down and the question is we've
put up so much goodness in the world the
United States and and Western world has
put up so much goodness related to
freedom we live in the freest country
ever we can do whatever we want in this
country and if your job all day long is
to write pieces that actually destroy
the stories that were built on and then
don't offer an alternative I mean that's
the thing they never offer an
alternative or if they do it usually is
about power to the state which is
actually dystopian not utopian so that's
what we have to watch out for and you
know it's unfortunate because they write
these things and then you know guys like
us we feel like we have to respond to
them because you don't want but I'm glad
we did because you just issued a
challenge a thing to the rest of us
which is create you know we need to
create well that's really mad let's
create let's do it Dave Rubin great to
see you